hello there mr rubin all right jp
january 1. we got anything good for the
people
well i don't know how good it is um
i guess we're going to find out how good
it is i'm it's not something i'm
thrilled about by any stretch of the
imagination
so you and i have been talking for a
couple of weeks now
ever since this scandal around carl
benjamin or
sargon of the cod broke and we decided
well a while back that we were going to
well do a variety of things right we
were going to
announce our departure from patreon
which is what we're doing in this video
i'm going to leave patreon january 15th
also am going to leave patreon on
january 15th
which by the way we should just be clear
this is not something that
we wanted to do we were both perfectly
happy on patreon patreon
at least for me it's been the the
backbone of my show i mean that's
somewhere between 60 and 70 percent of
our our funding
is through patreon so this is not
something we wanted to do i know we're
going to talk about a whole bunch of
things
in this recording but that new york
times article that came out
the implication was oh we're doing this
for money it's like
we're taking a major hit right now and
opening ourselves up to all sorts of
risks
so i'm going ahead and doing that
because i believe we can
do something better we've got to figure
out exactly what that is and that's what
we're working on
so we can say two things i mean i i'd
also like to thank the patreon people
for what they did in the past because
they provided me with a tremendous
amount of or the
ability the opportunity to generate a
tremendous
amount of financial support at a time i
really needed it and so
i'm not happy in the least with what has
happened i
have thought about it a lot and believe
that given
patreons proclivity to censor and the
reasons that they're doing it especially
as i've looked more and more deeply
into the reasons particularly with
regards to
my discovery of the website changed the
terms
i've become increasingly convinced that
it's unethical to continue my
association with the company
and i also agree jack conte said in that
new york times article
trying to justify say sam harris's
departure and our threatened departure
that
it was motivated primarily by financial
gain and
like look i've got nothing against
financial gain
you know i've said that from the
beginning i and if if
things that i'm doing generate uh an
honest
amount of money that i can put to
reasonable use then
so much the better but
if this is a major financial blow i'm
using the patreon money for a variety of
reasons
most particularly to support this
educational endeavor that i've talked to
people about write our attempt to build
an online education system and so like
it's a major hit
yeah and of course you know just to be
clear it's like when when we're doing my
show
i mean i don't have to tell everybody
about youtube demonetization but for
example
my show a week or two ago with imam
tuiti was demonetized by the algorithm
then demonetized
further after manual review by a human
so it's patreon
it's the supporters the individual
people that allow us to go ahead and do
more of these controversial so to speak
episodes
so yeah just nothing that we're doing
right now is against the people that
have supported us or our patrons or
anything like that
this is about making a stand against
this ever moving encroachment
on free speech on free expression and
the rest of it and it's like
this is one that we just feel is the
right one to make the move on
and the reason that we jointly decided
on january 15th well there was a couple
of reasons
the first was that we thought that we
might have something approximating an
alternative potentially available for
preliminary launch at that date although
we've decided to delay that because the
user interface needs work
because that's the other thing right is
that there needs perhaps to be a
replacement for patreon
if that's a possibility like it's not
obvious to me that
corporations can run platforms for
untrammeled communication successfully
on the net
in today's climate and yeah include
anything i might design
but let's not let's not gloss over that
i mean it might be possible that the
patreon method
is not what's needed exactly for the
future of the internet i mean this is
what we're trying to figure out right
now which is why we've got every
engineer i mean people from google and
facebook and yahoo and everybody
reaching out to us because it's like
everyone's trying to solve this problem
and it's still i mean one of the things
we've been talking about now for the
last
well it's really for the last year but
in intensely in the last month
is what actually is the problem itself
because until we really figure out what
the problem is
well i think i think the problem is
how to regulate an incredibly diverse
range of opinions
if such regulation needs to be
instantiated
we could take a limit case for example
the desire of companies like facebook
not to have their platforms used for
recruitment for isis
it's hard to make a case that that's not
a reasonable restriction
right but then but then the next issue
is
i think you could make an exception
there because maybe you consider that a
wartime exception or something like that
but then the fundamental problem to me
seems to be
and i'll return again to that change the
terms website that
a whole variety of companies and
organizations
spearheaded in not least by the southern
poverty law center that
hateful organization yeah the worst
that has decided that they're going to
uh compel encourage uh
what
the fame perhaps companies that don't
band together to
regulate what they see as hate speech
yeah and this is where well this is
where the moving line is the key part of
this because
you can always find the free the most
fringe cases you can always find
isis on one side and you know the most
fringe kkk
white supremacist group or whatever you
want to call it on the other side
but let's not forget southern poverty
law center they've written things about
you they've written things about me
ayan hersey ali and majin noise and sam
harris
and a litany of other good majid sued
them to
and actually won so there there is a
push back but this is just another level
of the stand it's like they cannot be
trusted
to be on the boards of any of these
organizations that are deciding what
terms of service yeah but they are
should have access
it's really who should have access to
the internet
it's yeah it's worse than that dave
because
when they start to pressure the credit
card companies and i would consider this
a warning to everyone who's listening
it's like okay
let's think this through so the new york
times last week wrote an article about
the credit card's complicity in loaning
money to that terrible tiny minority of
people who
engaged in mass shootings right stating
that it was
the responsibility of the credit card
companies to monitor and
potentially prevent that activity it's
like okay so so what's this
what's the idea here the idea is that
the companies to whom we have entrusted
our monetary system
in large parts that would be the credit
card companies now get to review our
spending patterns to determine if what
we purchase
is in accordance with that with what
they regard as morally acceptable
okay and and we think that's a good idea
that that's where we're headed
and and mastercard and visa and paypal
are already starting to block people
like april mastercard was instrumental
in blocking
spencer robert spencer right it's robert
spencer not richard spencer yes
it's his best-selling author and the guy
who runs g had watched mastercard
required patreon to de-platform him and
just to be very clear they sent out a
tweet which everyone can find i'm
shocked that they haven't deleted it yet
where they said that they and they use
this word which i think is the key to
the whole thing they said that they
unfortunately had to delete his patreon
because of
mastercard so what are they actually
saying there are is patreon saying oh we
didn't want to delete your page but
mastercard forced our hand i mean that
is some deeply scary stuff yeah well
and we have to talk about hate speech
because you know i think the whole
concept of look obviously there is uh
people can be very nasty when they
communicate
but the idea that that there's an
identifiable category
that that and you can put boundaries
around it and term at hate speech and
then you can produce committees
or deal with people on a one-to-one
basis as patreon
is doing without any central policy or
let's say
despite their central policy or that you
could turn that into an
algorithm that could validly identify
hate speech without producing
false positives right without accusing
people who shouldn't be accused of
violating
all of that's just completely it's just
beggars the imagination as far as well
of course and you're also just opening a
pandora's box from hell because just in
the last couple days i don't know if you
saw this but the women's march in
california canceled their rally because
they felt that it was too
white yeah now imagine if they canceled
their rally because it was too black
or too anything else it's like so does
that now count as hey are you guys now
being racist against white people now we
know that that wouldn't be a problem
for these guys one of the things that i
can't fathom
in some sense is the lack of imagination
on the part of the people who are
engaging in censorship of what they
regard as hate speech like
there's an old military adage which is
that if you invent a weapon it will be
used by your enemy within 15 years
okay so what what makes the people on
the
on the left because they're the ones who
are doing this what
as you can clearly see in the uh
change the terms website what makes them
so sure
that exactly the same tactics won't be
used against them
like at the drop of a hat once once the
tactics have been validated and put in
place
i think it's either it's either just
very short-sightedness on their hand or
they think that they can actually stamp
out enough hate within that
very small window before it would turn
on them or they just don't think these
things fully through but yeah yeah or
or there's another there's another
possibility too which is that
they're so opposed to the fundamental
structures of the west
that let's say and regard them as so
patriarchal and oppressive that they'd
be willing to take the risk of
sacrificing their own free speech
just to have their what have their
destructive way
something like that we should also
acknowledge that in the
the new york times piece that was
written which was written by nellie
bowles who wrote the
the now infamous piece about you and
enforce monogamy
uh that the quote that jacqueline hart
who is the head of uh trust and safety
over at patreon
the court there is no who has no
grounding in philosophy or any of the
of the background training that might be
necessary to even remotely begin to
participate properly in such a thing
no of course not but so the quote that
she gave nelly in the article
said that you can't say these i'm
loosely quoting this now
you can't say these words on our
platform referring to carl referring to
him
saying the n-word in that video yeah
which we which we know they were using
out of context and all that
but he never said it on their platform
he never said it on patreon
he didn't even say it on his own channel
that was you you know using patreon for
the funding
so there was a it's almost the entire
story was built
on quicksand that you know that tried to
put out there on the new york times now
of course
myself and many other people tweet the
hell out of it and gets hundreds and
thousands probably retweets and comments
to nelly and
and she doesn't respond nor does the new
york times issue any sort of
correction about the most fundamental
piece of the story
was a lie and they don't they don't have
a problem doing that so that's why this
is so layered about speech
and finance and journalism it's so
amazing to see
journalists take that journal like one
of the things that happened in canada
to me was that you know after i
made the initial videos that caused such
a political furor was that
once the main journalists in canada sort
of figured out what i was doing they all
came out
my support like the post media group
which is 200 newspapers all came out to
support what i was doing because they
realized that
well they're journalists apart from
comedians there isn't anybody who relies
more on the
principle of free speech to justify and
allow their occupation even to exist
for the new york times not to understand
that
this threat is also a threat to
everything upon which their
entire organization has been predicated
is also an indication of that same kind
of
willful blindness that we've already
been discussing but having said that i
would still like to say that i think the
biggest danger here
i really and it it's just made my jaw
drop over the last couple of
weeks thinking about it is the fact that
the credit card companies are now taking
it upon themselves
to potentially police the activities of
their users
it's like my god is that really i just i
i just can't believe that we
any sensible person would think that
through and then want to live in a
society where
your spending habits are being monitored
by
the company that basically produces your
money
yeah well think of anything more
totalitarian than that
to loosely quote our friend eric
weinstein should republicans be allowed
to use roads
that that's sort of where we're headed
here that every public good
will be eventually decided can you have
access to it will you have access to
water
should a should a an avowed white
supremacist right now that is
potentially watching this or lives in
america somewhere should be one of the
50 of them
one of the 42 of them should should they
have access to water at their home
should they allow to
get electricity at their home or phone
lines
or all of these things i mean this is
where we're headed especially when you
ever expand the definition of who that
person is
yeah they won't in china right there
well that's where they're going right so
is that the test case
well it i think it's it's an indication
that the fact that the chinese have been
tempted into this
is also an indication of the temptation
that's intrinsic in the technological
power
the credit card companies are in a weird
situation as far as i'm concerned
because the only reason
they work at all is because people
actually trust them
completely right it's like oh you're
just a proxy for money
like you're a proxy for cash in fact
that's basically how the mastercard
advertises itself right
so you're a proxy for cash and the
government doesn't watch what you spend
your money on except in extraordinarily
extraordinary limited cases i mean there
are money laundering laws and so
forth but that's in direct violation of
a law right that's part of tracking down
criminal activity that has nothing to do
so far with with hate speech
which by the way is protected by the
first amendment yeah so
or which means in some sense that it
doesn't exist you know as
a legal as a legal uh uh uh
concept right yes places like canada
which is right we shouldn't gloss over
that fact too because you know jordan we
just did however many countries
in in europe and we're going to go back
uh this spring and it's like
everybody that we met was jealous of the
freedoms that we have in the united
states
relative to speech you know what i mean
everybody that would come up to us after
the show holy cow i wish we could say
that and
i wish we didn't worry about this or
that or jokes or the rest of it and we
we did that video in oslo where you
talked about dankyla
and it's like they're jealous of our
freedom so
we should be very clear here though
you're right because
we now have a payment processor issue
which is
in in direct connection to whatever it
is
that we're trying to build out here and
we're still it's a little amorphous
at the moment yeah um is that it's
changing because a lot of people are
saying all right
you guys really want to solve this then
you have to go full crypto
yeah and i can the problem the video has
to be hosted crypto yeah the the
finances have to be hosted or have to be
done via crypto yeah all these things
these are these are major major things
that we're trying to figure out on every
front certain payment processors
are a little more willing to stand up to
the mob than others so we're talking to
different people i mean we're really
going on every front here that's right
well the tentative platform that we're
trying to build and to build carefully
will provide the possibility of multiple
payment
portals in the hope that the creators
will be less
susceptible to being rapidly shut down
or perhaps shut down at all
but it you know only a fool would say
that
that problem is going to be definitively
solved i have some real
and increasing sympathy for the
cryptocurrency types
you know but the problem there is that
as far as i can tell
their solution is still sufficiently
technically complex to keep it out of
the mainstream use and
also not sufficiently liquid
to actually constitute a realistic
current
replacement even for credit cards right
so one of the things we've been
discussing is that
it's almost like we have to have several
markers down the road
to figure out what the real solution is
because not everything can be solved in
terms of
terms of service tomorrow related to
everyone that exists not everything can
be solved tomorrow
related to the payment processors maybe
crypto really is the ultimate answer
but it's not the answer tomorrow for
everything so we're really
we're plotting out a lot here but it
seems like a fresh and sort of
fitting way to start the year i think so
and so for january
15th i mean part of the reason that we
picked that date
as i said before it was because we
thought we might have something to
announce with regards to an alternative
platform but
you know saner heads have prevailed in
that in that
commer yeah yeah yeah and also we wanted
to give people an
opportunity to decide what they wanted
to do without just springing it on them
i mean
i have some real admiration for harris
for acting so
immediately and definitively yeah
and it's funny you know i saw some
criticism it's like all right well sam
dropped
immediately and look you and peterson
you're still there and you're talking
about this whole thing and it's like
we all have different things to consider
we all have different family
situations different business situations
different livelihood situations
everything
so it's like we were really trying to
just plot this thing out properly and
and
to be very clear we're still in the
process of that
yeah so for any of so for anyone
watching this right now
if you're supporting jordan on on
patreon or you're supporting me on
patreon or both of us or whatever it is
it's like now we're trying to shift
people because at least by getting off
patreon at the moment we've removed
one of the middlemen and you can now go
directly
go to directly to jordanbpeederson.com
or davereuben.com and you can
at least if you want to donate you can
do that for now
while we figure out everything else and
that way we've
removed one of the pieces here because
there's just too many pieces here
that that are creating this mess i think
it's too much to
hope for a perfect solution to a very
complex problem
and we're muddling through the best we
can
and hopefully people will regard our
decision joint decision to
leave patreon as a step in the right
direction
however imperfectly taken yeah
and well look i think i i said it before
but i really think that
maybe this will be the defining uh
idea of 2019 is that i think we're
basically at the point
where people have to decide what sort of
internet they want
yeah and it's not only what sort of
internet it's really what sort of
freedom do you want
in in a digital world and either or do
you want any
or do you want any and maybe maybe you
don't or you don't want to think about
it and you just want to play fortnight
and watch porn and never think it
through
but yeah assuming that you'll be allowed
to watch porn
right so now you really are playing or
play for
that matter right so the the what makes
you think that
games of violence should be allowed what
makes you think that credit card
companies should allow you to use their
their funds to purchase first shoot
first person shooter games for example
or any game where anyone is killed
no you're you're totally right that's i
mean that sounds completely dystopian
and yet
it seems like that would just be the
next encroachment that we would see here
so the point at the end
at the end of this is i think everyone
for for 2019
since the first day of the year it's
like you have to think about what type
of internet do you want what type of
ability to communicate with other people
do you want and if you want something
that's a little better than what we've
got right now
we better stand up quick because this
window
we know it's closing slowly but we never
know when it's going to really slap shut
quick
so so we're working on it and and i
think people are ready to stand up with
us i really do
we might also suggest to people and this
is of course up to everyone who's
viewing this to decide
but you know a couple of thousand
letters to mastercard and paypal and
visa indicating pronounced displeasure
at their plans to become uh custodians
of the monetary supply for ethical
reasons
might also be in order you know these
companies are
responsive to public pressure which is
perhaps partly why they're determining
to play the role of censor to begin with
you know they're
they are facing pressure from these
let's call them
activist interest groups who again are
outlined on change the terms
on the website change the terms and
they're responding to
public pressure and to some that's
understandable
um it's understandable but
but inexcusable in certain in a certain
regard but
the right way perhaps to begin to push
back is to let the credit card companies
know that
there's a constituency on the other side
that i
i suspect constitutes the vast
majority of credit card users the silent
middle majority of let's say western
society
who are neither radically right nor
radically left who would just assume not
have their spending habits monitored by
giant corporations
it's pretty funny too that the left is
so opposed to
corporate entities you know on principle
especially the sizable ones
and you know have a certain
justification for being skeptical about
the moral direction of very large
organizations
um are so eager to hand over
the reins of social control to precisely
the companies you think they would be
least likely to crawl into bed with i
mean really mastercard and visa it's
like right
or at the same time they'll they want to
hand over more control to the government
to handle these things and and we should
be pretty clear
that in the last couple weeks that we've
been discussing this every single
discussion
that we've had about this i don't think
once did we entertain the idea of oh
we've got to get the government
involved to fix this thing i mean there
there could be as you as you referenced
earlier there could be specific
legal uh issues that pop up related to
collusion and a couple of other things
cartel developer yeah like that sort of
thing yeah but
but the beauty of this and again why i'm
so ins
i'm watching my my monthly rev of my
company go down even though we're making
some of it back but as i'm watching that
happen as i said to you last time
i'm incredibly inspired right now
because literally
thousands of emails are pouring in from
people that want to work with us that
want to help us that want to
figure out how to fund things or that
want to work as engineers of the rest of
it
and that tells you that that people are
people are afraid and they see this
problem
and they just want some solutions and
and maybe there isn't an easy solution
as you said
so i don't think i've also been talking
with you online with a whole bunch of
the people who've been loosely
aggregated under the aegis of the
intellectual dark web and
and that's probably 30 people that that
we've been communicating with
with a variety of peripheral people and
it's also
useful to let people know that every one
of those people is unbelievably
concerned about what happened to carl
benjamin to sargon and
even more so dumb struck by the
collusion of the payment processing
companies
and and the emergence of this activist
infrastructure online that's devoted
specifically to the suppression of
free speech yeah so well and also we
should also note that
within that group of say 30th semi
people we all
sort of look we agree on basic
fundamental principles related to free
speech and things like that but there's
a lot of disagreement on how to move
forward with this
i mean we're talking it out respectfully
as we always do but some people are
saying
stay and fight on patreon because this
is how you you know they're small enough
say
that you might get them to change some
people are saying you gotta go
some people are saying some version of
you know mixing those two
and nobody's clear about the proper
pathway forward
yeah but that's again i mean i think
this is what the brilliance of human
ingenuity is all about it's like
were there going to be some pitfalls in
front of us and staying would have its
risks and leaving would have its risks
and we're all going to do what we think
is right we've already discussed that
too right is that
there's a there's no there's no no risk
option here and
like and so we're taking the risk of
leaving
and then we're going to make the best of
it i mean often when you take a risk
often in life all you have is a choice
between two different risks and
sometimes
neither of them are risks you would like
to take but then
in the aftermath of the decision a new
field of possibility opens up in front
of you too and
whether or not you made the right
decision is actually a consequence of
how well you manage
the aftermath of the decision so we'll
we'll keep talking over the next couple
of months and on
like i've got good people working on
this
alternative you know which which was
as i mentioned in other places
started seven months ago or so and good
people supervising it
whether it'll turn out to be a viable
product and whether or not we can figure
out how to implement it in a sustainable
way that actually addresses
these issues in a reasonable manner
remains to be seen
yeah but hey on a personal note just
because uh you know i got to see you a
couple days before christmas in west
palm beach and
and we had dinner with uh with your
family and your kids and everything
hasn't it sort of been nice because i i
did a week with uh with my brother and
sister and nieces and nephews
over christmas also sort of circling
back to family on some of this
it it's given me a lot of perspective
you know what it's mean because i'm
getting i'm getting reached out by so
many different people on all different
fronts
but then to have sort of a close-knit
group of people that really do have
your interests in mind and all those
things yeah when there's
chatting with your kids at dinner it was
like oh these are good people to
well there's unanimity on the part of
the people around me that
the proper thing to do is well twofold
one is to
separate myself from patreon in
accordance with our discussions and the
second is to
proceed with exceeding caution and not
over promise
or try to deliver too quickly a solution
although to work on that carefully so
that's what we've decided to do
yeah so let's just be crystal clear on
that latter part we are working on this
we're going to be deliberate we're going
to be cautious we understand
that it can't be solved tomorrow we
understand that there's a financial part
a free speech part and everything else
and we're just going to lay these things
out in front of us and we're going to
keep working through them with a lot of
the people that you guys know and trust
yeah and and and with with some other
people
and hearing from random people that have
given us ideas i mean i've been
forwarding you emails left and right
where people are like you know this
might be the
the pressure point you might want to go
after so we're just going to keep going
yeah yeah okay well i got a couple
of things to end this i guess let's
summarize and then i've got a couple of
things just to let people know about
sure so um uh
the first is so we're both leaving on
january 15th and the second is we're
working on this platform
and the third is a warning to people to
keep a close eye on what the credit card
companies are up to because that's a
really bad thing in my estimation
i guess that's probably it on my front i
have a talk coming up in zurich i have a
couple of talks in
california in january yeah i'll be with
you on those
yep and the tickets to those are
available on my website
at jordanbpeterson.com the final thing
is
i also set up with my partners as a new
year's
uh token let's say the future authoring
program from the self-authoring suite
and we put it up at 50 off with the code
ny 2019 and so if anybody's
out there wants to make some personal
what do you call those resolutions for
the new year
then this program is an ideal way of
doing that and so
that's also partly a thank you to
everyone who um
has been so supportive and interested in
the last year
and so i think that's basically
i think that's basically that what do
you think all right no i think that's
basically it so i'll just quickly
uh you know give a shout out to dave
rubin.com
donate and what what we're trying to do
and i know you're trying to do this as
well
is that for whoever signs up now and
we're taking it's one time and
monthly donations that you can do there
are going to be ways that we think once
we build out whatever it is we're
working on that
that it'll all be able to be flipped
into that so it's not like we're gonna
have people constantly having to start
new accounts or or you know sign up for
new things or anything like that we're
trying to make this as easy as possible
for everybody and they'll look there's
gonna be some bumps but
this is good that's one thing say about
2019
there's gonna be there's gonna be some
bumps well
i don't know if you know this jordan but
we got an american election coming the
year after that so okay
mr rubin happy new year all right happy
new year brother i'll see you in uh in
cali in a couple weeks
bye for now